*legendary intro* (rip headphone users :(
1 sub = 1 PERSONAL HARAMBE SEX CLONE
The most HARDCORE game
The most hardcore game
Made by two manly man
Cinnamontoastken
Cinnamontoastken: *totally attractive noise*
Pewds: I challenge you
Cinnamontoastken: *another attractive noise*
Pewds: For Rock Paper Sissa
*horse noises*
OOOOHHHHHHHH
AAAAAHHHH (oh my)
OOOOHHH
so manly
*badass music*
pewdiepie: but wait
There's a twist..
whoever *wins gets to control the other person's computer remotely
via advanced technology
for 30 seconds
Poods: oh ma god.... (pray4pewds)
Cinnamontoastken: I won't lose to you pewdiepie
Pewdiepie: Oh we will see about dat...Kennnnnnn..
Ken: Sheeeeit
Pewdiepie: I am scared...
Pewds: this is such a dumb idea (yeh it is)
I've never seen anyone do this on youtube...
that's how you know its a bad fucken idea... (poods specialty)
Cinnamontoastken: Everyone else is like... no fucking way...
*Laughs*
Pewdiepie: Oh wait.. Rock, paper, scissors
I don't even know if it's gona work out we'll just give it a try
We're gonna do rock paper sissa
You ready?
Ken: I'm ready
*Intense music*
Cinnamontoastken: Are you ready for this?
Pewdiepie: Oh yeah.... babe!
Cinnamontoastken: ARE YOU READY FOR DIS!!
Pewdiepie: NOOOOOOOOOOOO!
NOOOOOOO
NOOOOOO!
Cinnamontoastken: YES! I DID IT
Cinnamontoastken: EH We getting to hacking into da pewdiepie's computer
Pewdiepie: Please
Cinnamontoastken: Start the cool hacking montage!
(Hacking time with ken.mp3)
Pewdiepie: Alright Ken! 30 seconds
Pewds: ALRIGHT KEN 30 SECONDS
Pewdiepie: NOO!
Pewdiepie: GET OUT OF THERE KEN!
Cinnamontoastken: Oh yeah!
Pewdiepie: GET OUT OF THERE!
Cinnamontoastken: Finally!
Pewdiepie: What are you gonna do?
Cinnamontoastken: My one chance!
Noo!
Cinnamontoastken: Awww ye
Pewdiepie: NOOOOOOOOO!
Pewdiepie: NOO, DON'T DELETE MY CHANNEL KEN
Cinnamontoastken: CLICK IT! CLICK IT!
Pewdiepie: PLEASE!
Cinnamontoastken: YESSS!
Pewdiepie: NOOOO!!
Cinnamontoastken: YEEESS HAH!
Pewdiepie: 30 SECONDS!!! YOU BITCH!
Cinnamontoastken : WHAT THE FUCK? YOU FUCKED ME UP!
Pewdiepie: oh that was close
That was close one...
Cinnamontoastken: Rematch betch!
Pewdiepie: Alright i will get ya this time, you son of a bitch!
Cinnamontoastken: Yeah, sure you will..
Pewdiepie: You think you're in my head?
Cinnamontoastken: I am in your head
Pewdiepie: (whispers) come on
*inaudible whispering*
EH
Cinnamontoastken: ehhh~
Pewdiepie: OHHHHHh!
Cinnamontoastken: FUCK!!!
Pewdiepie: That's right
Pewdiepie: ITS PAYBACK TIME BITCH!
Cinnamontoastken: Nooooo!
I-I wasn't really gonna delete y-your shit I promise
Pewdiepie: Oh you were gonna delete my channel
Pewdiepie: Let me just connect to your shity piece of shit
Cinnamontoastken: OH SHIT! WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN THERE?
NO NO PLEASE GOD NO!
DON'T DO IT!
Cinnamontoastken: I am a huge..
Pewdiepie: GOD DAMN IT!
Cinnamontoastken: faaaa uhh
Cinnamontoastken: Oh u got 10 Seconds LEFT!
Cinnamontoastken: Fucken..
Eh Oh....!  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Cinnamontoastken: Time is almost up!
Cinnamontoastken: Get the fuck outta there!
Pewdiepie: NOOO! Are u kidding me?
That's all I had..
Cinnamontoastken: It goes by so fast!
Alright, I got that ass this time
You're going down!
Pewdiepie: It's fucking delayed.. fucked me over
*laugh*
Ken: Maybe we should give you more time maybe-
Pewdiepie: AHHHH!!
Cinnamontoastken: Fuck yeah
Yes!
Cinnamontoastken: But yeah, maybe we should give each other more time
Pewdiepie: No... No I think we are good
Pewds: Naaah I think we were good
Ken: Yeeh
Cinnamontoastken: Oh yeah?
Pewdiepie: I think we're good
Cinnamontoastken: Uhhh
Pewdiepie: What are you doing in my channel trailer?
Cinnamontoastken: Awwww yeah
Cinnamontoastken: There's a url I can't see
Pewdiepie: What are you pasting?
Pewdiepie: That's the wrong paper scissor link, you dumb fuck
Cinnamontoastken: FUUUCK!!
Cinnamontoastken: Where did it go? God damn it
Pewdiepie: That's it you blew it
(laughs)
Pewdiepie: YOU BLEW IT!!
Cinnamontoastken: Dammit NOOO
It was so good and I blew it
Pewdiepie: Come on
Cinnamontoastken: Jesus Christ
Cinnamontoastken: Alright, you won't pick the same thing twice, right?
OH FUCKING
Cinnamontoastken: Absoulute power
Pewdiepie: I HATE THIS GAME
Cinnamontoastken: Going back in
Pewdiepie: NO! DAMMIT! I FORGOT TO CLOSE IT
Cinnamontoastken: I'll get it this time
YES!
Okay
Super hacking skills
Do I put an 'o'? I can't read
Pewdiepie: You got 20 seconds bitch! You better type fast
Cinnamontoastken: Oh god dammit. Did it work?
Pewdiepie: I'm not the owner of the video it doesn't work
Cinnamontoastken: Why didn't it work?
Cinnamontoastken: Dammit
Pewdiepie: You got denied bitch
Pewdiepie: What is this video?
Video Ken: I'm CinnamonToastKen
And if you're watching this video
then you're not subscribed to PewDiePie
and you must hate him just as much as me
Pewdiepie:Oh you fucking bitch
Video Ken: You should go over to the CinnamonToastKen channel because its like, WAAAY better.
Pewdiepie: did you make this for this?
ken: Ya-
Ken: That's why I was like
Pewdiepie: You sly son of a bitch
Ken: Hang on i gotta finish this one thing
Ken: and it doesn't fucking work!
Ken: DAMN IT!
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Pewdiepie: have you been seeing on my screen on what I click on?
(yes)
Ken: uh no (?)
(Liar!)
Pewdiepie: yOU FUCkIN ASSHoLE
Pewdiepie: OH I'M SO PISSED IM SHAKING (pats poods)
ken: get rekted n00b
Pewdiepie: I forgot it was on!
ken: oh no I can't see your screen anymore (sad)
Ken: it was so easy before why- why is this so hard now
godammit!
Pewds: thats right!
I didn't want to do this to you ken
Ken: Oh no don't do it
Pewds: done
Pewds: Next one
ken: NOO! he- nO PLEASE GOD
30 Seconds cant come bo- AAA NOOO HO HO
nOOOO
OH OH  NOO
(rip ken and poods)
Poods: I'm seeing it too alright
Ken: alright here we go
cmon baby
Ken: ah fak!
Poods: WELL WELL weLL
Ken:don't make me watch more gay porn please! (I know you like it //shot)
Ken: I'll jus-- Omy god noho ho xD
nooo
Pewdiepie: Please please make it so you saved your password
Pewdiepie: YYYEEESSS
Cinnamontoastken: GODDAMNIT!
Ken: I'm broke though theres nothing in there (sure Ken)
sHit
Poods: oh hell yaa
no nO DAMMIT
poods: K lets do a final one
Ken: Alright
Alright alright
Cmon baby!
Poods: oh your just gonna lose! You son of a bitch
ken: hngggg neveral
(little ken celebration)
poods: NOOO
Ken: yES!
poods: plz ken I wasn't actually gonna send any money (Yeah sure, Papa pewds)
Ken: yeeaahh you trying to get into my paypal
poods: it was just a joke (prank)
Ken: son of a bitch
what is this? (facebook//its twitter)
let me check dem dms real quick
Poods: nO uh don't check my
get out of my dms! you son of a bitch
*i spotted Marina Joyce...*
poods: nO NOT LEAFY
Ken: oh ya
Poods: no not to leafy!
Ken: send that sht woo!
*arousing groan*  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Poods: wait wtf is this?
ken: can't stop me I'm in >:D
Now for your favorite video(Stop torturing poods ;-;)
of all taim!
Ken:where is it?
is that it?
thats yout00be wtf
ah yeah lovely story fuck yes lovely story
Poods:NOOOOOOO
yeSSS YESS
Ken: WHAT THE FUCK IS MY F*PPENING?
Poods: thank you ken
gotta scroll AAAAAAA
tanks for da virus, KeN
Cinnamontoastken: I'm sorry for sake wat happened
//Screaming poods
ken: I can see it too noOO
pewds: take it
ken: I take it all back
//More yells
ken: haahhhahhh bitches
poods: It looks like you win this round cinnamontoast ken (does that mean there will be a new round?)
ken: the most dangerous game on the planet
pewds: this is a shitty idea
fuckin hell
Subscribe
you can go now
your view counts now
leafy responded!
"We can 69..."
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)